and now to the United States we're in
fighting has broken out within the
Democratic Party as a result of
perceived anti-semitic statements from
one of their own members than one of
their own members who happens to be one
of the first Muslim women to serve in
Congress House Democrats will introduce
a resolution tomorrow condemning
anti-semitism the text will not mention
Minnesota representative Ilhan Omaha by
name but the rebuke is seen as a
response to a comment she made on Sunday
she said that the pro-israel lobby in
the United States is pushing for
allegiance to a foreign country and this
is the latest in an ongoing struggle
between the Democratic leadership and a
small number of freshmen Democrats
who've been a vocal about pushing the
party further to the left we get more
our mission or my dwz on a safer welcome
Amy on so why did Democrats find her
statement so offensive well the
statement she made the original one on
Sunday was at an event but she tweeted
about it again and reiterated the
statement and we can see that tweet now
the problem at the center of it was her
use of the idea of you know allegiance
to a foreign country which the the
anti-defamation league and other top and
top Democrats have pointed out is an
anti-semitic trope that's been used
against the Jewish community for a long
time to say that there on the one hand
they have an allegiance to their own
country but also an allegiance to the
wider Jewish Diaspora but others like
Democratic Representative Juan Vargas
has gone further and said that all
criticism of us support for Israel is
unacceptable and he's basically just
pointing out a platform of the Democrat
and Republican parties that Israel has
and always will be a US ally so has
anyone come to ilhan omos defense
definitely there have been a lot of
left-wing commentators who have pointed
out also journalists who have pointed
out that her comments were not against
Jewish Congress people but against any
Congress person who supports Israel
because of the money they get from the
pro-israel lobby in the US she also has
support from a core group of other
Democratic Congress people who came in
on the Democratic wave that happened in
the last elections young progressive
Congress people who've come to her
support and said actually she's being
attacked because she's Muslim which adds
another element to this whole story they
have pointed out that at the same time
that the Democratic Party the leadership
is attacking her for being anti-semitic
they she is the the object of
Islamophobic attacks
there's a picture circulating online of
actually a poster that was at a
Republican event in West Virginia an
official Republican event that links her
to 9/11 of course I don't have to say
there is no link the only link that they
have there is that she's Muslim so
another way a layer of weirdness and
this is the the fact that this is
Democrats censoring one of their own
that's right it comes off as strange but
it's no surprise that the Democratic
Party is having an internal crisis right
now maybe not a crisis but definitely a
struggle between two different elements
you have the Democratic leadership which
tends to be more conservative more
centrist and then you have a new what
some people are referred to as an
insurgency of more left-wing people like
Ilhan Omar Alexandria Ocasio Cortes who
are challenging the the platform of the
Democratic Party and there's resistance
and so how I was just going to affect
I'll hand over well the resolution is
mostly symbolic like I said it doesn't
mention her by name Trump president
Donald Trump has called for her to
resign other members of Congress have
said that she should step down for the
Foreign Affairs Committee that's not all
that's also not likely to happen she's
been pushing
she's been reiterating her points that
she's against Israel lobby but she's may
also be happy that this has confirmed
her original point that any time one
criticizes a link between the Israel
lobby and us support for Israel you
might get censured and that's a taboo
that she's willing to break yeah si
thank you